In preparation for most sermons, and in particular this one, I read a lot of other
people's thoughts on this text.
I read other sermons,
I skimmed many commentaries.
Most of them had really cute titles,
like "Quite a Catch,"
"Fishing for Christ,"
or-- by far the most popular--
"Gone Fishin'."
Well, those get a little cheesy for my taste, but the
one that caught my attention was
"Get Outta Here." Hm.
I don't like to judge a book by its cover,
or a commentary by its title, so I read on,
and discovered that Will Willimon, Methodist bishop,
had written about this very Gospel text a
few years ago in the Christian century.
He commented on how the crowd was pushing
in on Jesus,
finally starting to maybe understand what
he was about, attracted to his sermons and his
words,
but there was Simon.
Simon, witness to this crazy unbelievable
miracle,
and all Simon could say is,
"Get away from me, Lord!"
Or-- Willimon's translation--
"Get outta here!"
Well, "get out of here" seems, maybe, the most
appropriate response,
because what do we normally say when we hear
the crazy, unbelievable, too good to be true
miracles in the Gospel?
Get outta here.
Or what do we say when we hear Jesus
calling us
out to the deep water?
Get outta here.
A sarcastic yet quite honest response that
we might find ourselves saying quite often
to the call of God.
When I was a freshman in college,
my chaplain pulled me aside
the beginning of the second semester and said,
"Have you considered seminary?"
Well, it had been a long semester of fishing
for the right major,
not catching
anything,
cleaning my nets after final exams, wondering
if all of the work was just in vain.
But I was also very content in my little small
boat with my Communications major and my tightly
held dreams to be on the radio someday.
But I think
God was speaking through Chaplain Brian that
day when he nudged me to consider exploring
ministry.
"Well, have you thought about seminary?" he said
again.
My quick and baffled answer was, "Uh, no."
Translation:
get outta here.
And then I had to also ask,
"What's seminary?"
He explained more, and I said, "Uh, no. No, thank you.
I'm very content in my small boat with my communications
major and my tightly held dreams to be on the radio."
But after each semester, when I was cleaning
my nets, wondering if my work was in vain,
he would find yet another creative way to
drop this hint,
subtly or not so subtly.
So we were cleaning up from an evening service,
he would say, "Well, we are offering a course
this winter on exploring careers in ministry
in case you're interested."
My silence became my way of saying,
get outta here.
But simultaneously there was this nagging
curiosity growing,
and I hardly noticed that I was gradually
and repeatedly being invited
to go out to the deep water.
This invitation came not only from Chaplain Brian but another voice that I didn't understand--
a voice that promised risk and also hope,
a voice that assured me I wasn't going to
do it alone.
But this pull out to deep water was a much slower
process than
for Simon and company.
It took years.
It's still going on.
I don't think deep water is a place we can
ever get too comfortable;
there're too many dangers out there, too much
unknown. But
before we know it,
the tide has pushed us back to the shore,
back to a place of the safe, secure, shallow
water.
Until God once again calls us out into the
deep, and we have to decide
yet again
how we will respond.
I'm not going to bore you with the rest of
the story of how I got into ministry,
and I do want to make it really clear
that following the call of Jesus does not necessarily
mean pursuing professional ministry.
In fact, another mentor in college turned to me
when he heard I was considering this, and said
"If you can do anything else
besides be a pastor, you should do it."
He was a little burned out himself.
But he was also
saying, if God is inviting you
to the deep waters of some other calling,
you better get in that boat--
the boat made for you.
Well, when it comes to the call of the disciples,
by the lake shore, each of our four Gospels
tells a similar story but emphasizes different
details, which I think are really important.
In Matthew and Mark, we hear a very short
story about the call of Simon and Andrew,
brothers called to be disciples.
Jesus gets right to the point. He walks up
to them.
They are fishing off the shore.
And he just says, "Follow me. I'll make you fish for people." That's it.
They dropped their nets.
Jesus continues down the shore
to James and John.
"Follow me. I'll make you fish for people."
They drop their nets.
That's it.
In the Gospel of John--
never as brief--
Jesus stands on the shore and calls out to
the disciples out there in the fishing
boat, "Hey, have you caught any fish?"
"No."
"Well just try throwing the nets in on the other side of the boat."
And they were full.
That's how it happens
for John.
And instead of Simon saying "get outta here,"
or some version of that,
Simon actually gets out of there himself.
He is so stunned in the Gospel of John that
he jumps out of the boat.
But Luke
chooses to tell it another way.
Jesus gets into the boat
with Simon.
Jesus is back on the beach in the other Gospels.
He's in the boat in Luke.
And he tells Simon to row out to the deep water,
the only time in the four Gospels that it involves
deep water.
Simon explains they've been fishing all
night and haven't caught a thing,
but agrees to give it a try.
And they instantly catch a bunch of fish.
And we know that Simon is so in awe of the
presence of Jesus that he tells him,
"Get out of here!"
He feels unworthy to be in the presence of
God, in the presence of this miracle worker,
Jesus.
But instead of Jesus
just saying,
"Follow me" as we hear in Matthew and Mark,
Jesus instead tells Simon,
"Do not be afraid.
From now on you will be
catching people."
So the gift of having these four slightly
different versions in the Gospels is that
we have at least four different lenses through
which we can hear
and see this story.
In this year of reading Luke's Gospel together,
in this day of hearing Luke's miraculous fishing
story,
Luke's lens
gives us some unique ways to consider discipleship.
Now discipleship is one of those words we
throw around a lot here at this church.
We sing about being called disciples of
Jesus.
We pray for strength to do it. We hear texts
like today's about the disciples of Jesus.
And yet,
discipleship might not be one of those words
you say ever outside of these walls.
The twelve disciples can be put on such a
pedestal in our minds,
that we forget just how
imperfect, just how much like us,
they are.
Thus the task of discipleship
can seem so inflated
and become one of those
"I'll never get it right and may as well not try"
kinds of things.
And yet we are somehow drawn back here,
to this place, to this text,
to ask what it means
for us.
Luke's story of the miraculous catch of fish
and the invitation to Simon
to take up a different kind of fishing
might be able to help us decode the loaded word of
discipleship.
Now I hate
tidy three-point sermons.
But somehow I have distilled this next section
down into three tidy points. Ok.
Discipleship
in Luke.
Number one:
Jesus asks his disciples to go into the deep
water
but goes with them.
That is key.
If discipleship
means getting into your metaphorical boat
and going into your metaphorical deep waters,
then it is crucial to remember that for Luke,
the deep water happens only
when Jesus gets in the boat with the disciples.
Where do you sense the presence of God?
Is it sometimes in those moments when you
experience risk
or stretching out of your comfort zone?
Jesus rarely calls us
to the convenient,
comfortable, complacent shallow waters.
But Jesus doesn't call you to places where
he hasn't gone or isn't willing to go.
Your deep water is going to be different
than anyone else's deep water.
Being here this morning might feel like you're
being thrown in the deep end.
Completely unfamiliar, this might feel terribly
risky,
and for other people this might feel right at
home.
Regardless of what the deep water is for you,
here's the truth for Luke:
if Jesus calls you to the deep water
he's going with you.
Second:
Jesus asks his disciples to be honest,
and then calms fears.
So discipleship is being
honest
with Jesus.
Simon doesn't pretend to be all holy
when he witnessed the miracle of the fish.
Instead he just blurted out his
honest,
fear-filled truth,
acknowledging that he didn't feel worthy
to be in the presence of Jesus.
Also,
Jesus senses Simon's fear
in this response.
Simon says, "Get out of here," and Jesus says,
"Don't be afraid."
Jesus can take your honesty even if it
seems rude.
So if you sense that God might be nudging you in
some direction that you just can't imagine
going,
you may as well be honest. Wrestle it out with
God a bit.
"Get out of here" for Simon
was his honest and actually pretty humble response
to nets so miraculously full of fish.
When Jesus gets in the boat,
you won't be able to hide very much,
but your honesty will be matched with Christ's
fear-calming comfort and presence.
And third:
discipleship might invite you to leave
those nets behind,
even as they are bursting
with fish.
Yeah.
This-- the disciples just leave their nets and follow
him, and this might sound even
scarier than the deep water.
It's not logical
for the disciples to leave.
They did not sit down and calculate how much that was going to cost them in losses.
Logic was left way back there in the shallow
water a long time ago for them, though.
It wasn't logical to follow Jesus out into the
deep water after a night of pointless fishing.
It wasn't logical for them to leave their nets
bursting with
finance and security.
It was not logical,
but Jesus
isn't logical.
Discipleship
might not be logical.
It's not a matter of just
rearranging the pieces of our lives to make
room for God somehow.
Discipleship
is being willing to walk away from all
those pieces
to follow Christ.
Youu might not be called to leave family
or business or goals behind.
But discipleship
calls us to be willing to do that,
or at least keep all of those pieces
in perspective.
Discipleship is a willingness to follow
Jesus into the unknown,
and I know that's terribly vague and abstract,
especially for those of you grasping for
some clear picture of what your future's
going to hold.
You list pros and cons,
we get everyone's expert opinion about what
we should do, we try to please family members
or advisers--
but all of this may not help you, in the end,
to feel certain.
Poet Wendell Berry writes,
"It may be that when we no longer know what to do,
we have come to our real work."
And that when we no longer know which way
to go, we have come to our real journey.
So all I'm saying is
that there may be a time
when you feel drawn to do something for reasons
you cannot explain,
in ways that don't make financial sense or
please other people,
and that might be exactly what
you are supposed to do. Amen.